Prime Minister we've had the first
casualty today what's your response and
how worried should people be well
obviously our sympathies are very much
with the victim and their family but the
situation is is pretty much as it has
been in the sense that we're still Sam
in the in the contained phase so now our
scientists and medical advisors are
making preparations for the delay phase
and so what they're looking at in the
next few days in the in the in the near
future is what kind of measures might be
necessary to [ __ ] the spread of the
disease as soon as they've decided that
the moment is right to announce those
I'll make sure we will be absolutely
clear with the public about what needs
to be to be done but for the moment
things are as they have been and you
know I'm gonna say this the best single
thing we can do is wash our hands two
verses of the national anthem or happy
birthday hot water bar so the number of
people with the condition is over a
hundred you really people saying people
shouldn't change their behavior beyond
just washing their hands we've been
waiting for the government to change its
as it were status the level of this
condition we seem to be quite cautious
about doing that are you too worried
about making people nervous about this
no no I mean we're just I mean literally
that that's the right thing to do
present given where we are in the
epidemiological progress you know this
the could I tell you why it's because in
in something like this what they what
the scientists say is that you've got a
range of things that you can do to
arrest or check the spread of a DS but
you can't fire your shots too early it's
all about the timing and the progression
and so they're thinking very carefully
about when that next a suite of measures
that next that those next options are
used and one thing I'm absolutely we
will be telling everybody as soon as we
get that medical advice finally but just
for today people are to keep the same
travel plans the same work plans the
same school plans as they did last week
in the week
obviously there's a there's been a
change of advice on on Italy I believe
but basically we're saying wash your
hands and business as usual were still
in the container
phase obviously were well looking at the
the preparations we need to make now for
delay